hello all of the internet I'm gas I'm
Dan we're the slow mo guys and yes it is
that time of year again we've got
another six foot giant red balloon here
classic got a few of those now yeah yeah
done you jumping on a big blue for the
water on it me in a big balloon for the
water being a me in a big balloon full
of air in it so what's next under it
under it I think under it so we've got
this trampoline and we'll put this on
you and start to fill with water until
it either pops or you get crushed to
death
brilliant I know which one's best yeah I
like that your idea of me being crushed
to death is being made more comfortable
by being on a trampoline
I'd be fine soft on the ground but also
the water won't pull around you when it
pops it will just go straight through
consider it sorry consider it this is
the first in a series of videos that I'm
gonna call giant balloon Jun which
honestly I'm quite proud of that me I'll
download that so we'll be doing just
giant balloon videos in June we'll try
and get a few of them out and uh let's
start with this one all right off we go
cue the Sun I'm excited to be doing
another walkthrough video actually yeah
just like this is bringing back old
memories we're experts at this are we
very good all right we're just
moistening down the trampoline just to
get the black material cooler cuz it's
been absorbing heat all morning okay so
position the balloon on yourself so
ridiculous
alright here we go that's already heavy
with it yeah
ah get a really good shot of my double
chin here
well the bid covers it don't it the
comfiest thingy mark no don't think it
would be a good fashion accessory it
looks like you've got a big beam yeah I
reckon I'm hotter than you are oh yeah
sounds like laser fire had to get a
higher angle on the phantom because it's
synced so much yeah people won't blame
on that over a thousand pounds no yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
is this video guys gonna be putting
tremendous strain on the springs at this
point should we have safety collars do
you think oh bugger
what get pins and needles at my feet
it's like turn off the blood circulation
we're gonna have to amputate
ah this is definitely one of those
moments in my life where I'm like how
did I find myself in this situation
I might take those goggles you know yeah
yeah I think I'm much prefer being in it
because it's over my knees yeah yeah
it's like bending my knees backwards the
wrong way because o because because the
trampoline does that my legs are like
that at the Palouse pressed on them
which means that my legs are like being
bent backwards
oh nice oh cool this one
crushed by a six-foot water balloon you
look like something like a Mr Man which
missed at which one of the Vista men was
a red circle it's so big now all right
you did you know compensation for me
yeah are you wearing a fork no I'm not
wearing it for the balloon wait for the
spring spider what I have to pop it soon
yeah just for just for your own safety
yeah just my leg I don't want to a
potato flake
ah I've done you go my leg it's gonna
come off in a minute
show me how you want me to do it right
here yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
thoughts
it gave me jelly legs
we always lost a leg from a balloon dad
the things you go through for this chat
oh oh commendable
you know what boom people take their
first steps after spending like a year
in space Bambi
yeah okay yeah good good stand again
just about I've never seen jelly legs
like that you don't you see like
marathon runners get that yeah I'm a
zombie legs yeah I had nothing there how
far away we were from some permanent
damage it's like your ball when that got
twisted around its own blood supply and
got cut off that it was the entirety of
my lower leg that I couldn't feel any
more waist because the trampoline it
actually made it worse because I was
like my leg was bent under this under
the weight like that so it's like go in
the wrong way you could just never
underestimate the weight of war like if
that was dropped from above onto your
head if you like it hit my brick kiln it
you'd absolutely be killed
yeah well that was enjoyable for you
yeah yeah well yeah hopefully for them
too hopefully for the audience as well
hmm what um be cheers I know love to
crack on with another one now tune in
again for balloon Juden big old balloon
Schulich sweet next week a new video a
new big balloon
crustier boss or twitter subscribe to
the main channel second channel maximych
and buy submerge if Dan sees you wearing
that merch you will buy you a drink
probably see you next week